well on the Korea Council we were
talking about the number of issues
related to new models one of the key
topics that we talked about was the
issue of regional cooperation how to
improve it and also possibly also
enhance and enlarge it so far regional
cooperation means Korea Japan and China
we were thinking about including more
partners into that including Southeast
Asia the other big issue we were talking
about was North Korea North Korea
currently being more a challenged in an
opportunity and we think that looking
into the future this not only has to
change but it also will change North
Korea is an issue including nuclear
problems including economic problems
including humanitarian problems but all
that can be solved in a positive way are
actually contributing to an improvement
many many areas within that region and
this is one of the key topics we've also
been talking in the Council on career
and we are still going on